تهانينا الفوضوية الصغيرة على حصولك على
لقب أفضل رياضي مجيد لهذا العام،
ماذا يعني هذا بالنسبة لك،
شكرًا جزيلاً لك، الحقيقة هي أنه
لشرف كبير أن تكون قادرًا على الحصول على هذه
الجائزة لتتمكن من الدخول مع العديد من
الرياضيين العظماء الذين كانوا فائزين سابقًا  إن
الترشيح إلى جانب شخصيات
من رياضات أخرى أمر لا يصدق، لذلك نحن
سعداء جدًا بهذا التكريم،
لذا أنا مندهش كم مرة
تفكر فعليًا في قطر وتفكر
في تلك اللحظات من 18 ديسمبر،
حسنًا، قطر تظهر دائمًا، إنها
لحظة خاصة جدًا  في مسيرتي المهنية في حياتي،
وبينما يوجد دائمًا وقت
لتذكر تلك اللحظة من كأس العالم
التي استمتعنا بها كثيرًا لمدة شهر،
وهناك دائمًا ذكريات جميلة متبقية
وستكون مدى الحياة، ما الذي جعلك
تفعل هذا؟  فريق الأرجنتين
مميز
جدًا، لا أعرف ما الذي يجعله
مميزًا جدًا، الحقيقة هي أنه مجموعة
تعمل معًا
لفترة من الوقت حيث نستمتع بما نقوم به عندما
نكون معًا
ونتشارك كل اللحظات يومًا بعد يوم.
مجرد التدريب والمباريات ولكن الاستمتاع
بكوننا معًا
والمنتخب الأرجنتيني
مميز للغاية كما هو الحال دائمًا، ليس فقط لهذه
المجموعة ولكن لجميع اللاعبين الذين اضطروا
لارتداء القميص الأرجنتيني،
وارتداء قميص المنتخب الوطني أمر
مميز جدًا للجميع، هل
هذا عادل؟  إن القول بأن تغيير رأيك هو
أفضل قرار في حياتك
هو أمر
جيد، والحقيقة هي أنه كان
وقتًا صعبًا بالنسبة لي عندما شعرت أنه يجب أن
يكون الأمر بهذه الطريقة، ولحسن الحظ تمكنت لاحقًا
من عكس تلك الفكرة أو تلك الكلمة التي
قلتها.  وتمكنت من الاستمتاع بها
مرة أخرى وأدركت ما
يعنيه المنتخب الأرجنتيني بالنسبة لي، والقدرة على
الفوز بجميع الألقاب
يجعل الأمر أكثر خصوصية، لقد
فزت بكل شيء، لقد فعلت كل شيء،
ما هو أكثر من ذلك  الشيء المهم بالنسبة لك
الآن هو المضي قدمًا،
كرة القدم هي الشيء الذي
أحببته منذ أن كنت طفلاً، أحببت
اللعب بها وأحب الحياة اليومية، لقد
كانت حياتي كلها أن أتمكن من الاستمتاع
بما أحبه، أنا فقط أبحث عنه  هذا هو الاستمرار في الاستمتاع بمواصلة
اللعب وهو
ما جعلني سعيدًا دائمًا طالما كان
هذا هو الحال وأستطيع أن أستمر في
القيام بذلك ويجب أن
أسأل قبل أن ننتهي، لقد
حصلت على هذه الجوائز التي
تقف هنا مع ذلك  بين يديك، هل
انتهى النقاش، هل أنت الآن
الأعظم رسميًا،
حسنًا، لم تكن الأفكار التي كانت لدي
طوال مسيرتي المهنية ولم أكن أبحث
عن ذلك مجرد حقيقة اعتباري
من بين أسماء الأشخاص الذين
يفكرون أو يقولون كوني من بين هؤلاء
مهما كان
عشرة خمسة ثلاثة من يريدون، فهو
جنون بالفعل، لم ألعب كرة القدم أبدًا من أجل
ذلك ولكن من الواضح أنني ممتن لأن
الناس يفكرون بهذه الطريقة وبصراحة أنا
لا أعطي أهمية لأي
منصب مهما كان